you talk about how you're a
self-professed nerd you embrace your
nerdiness and yeah and the things you
love from nerd dumb what are the nerdy
things are into these days well for me
it's a huge thing I like Star Wars again
yeah because I hated it because before
that I loved it and then before what
before before I hated it I loved it oh
but then I took about what star wars did
to me really personally yeah I don't
know if you know any other 50 old nerds
that were bad at a movie but I'm one of
them and so here's you like the first
three I like the first and then I took
the prequels and the special editions
like they were done to me personally and
you got so last year when people were
excited about force awakens I'm like
they're not getting me again you're not
getting you're not tricking me again and
then my friends are like dude what about
Han and Chewie did you see the trailer
with Han and Chewie and I'm like I
didn't feel anything my heart's made of
turds you know what I made them but then
I saw it and I was a win opening day and
I loved it like I teared up I cried I
cried during the whole thing I cried at
the scroll it was like Luke Skywalker's
vanished online I was like Toy Story 3
me sound like Chewie two best friends
together again I cried when they showed
the Millennium Falcon I was like my
favorite ship from life super emotional
my wife is like did you like it and I'm
like I loved it she goes no he cried
during the whole goddamn
I have emotional and so she goes well
you can talk about it to your buddy Rick
and we go to my buddy Rick's house I'm
all excited to talk about Star Wars and
I see him and I'm like dude force
awakens I loved it he goes I hated it
and then we fought for three hours
like everything he said I had an answer
to he's like well the plot felt too
familiar and I'm like familiar like
comfort food like mashed potatoes you
dumb dick yeah that sounds terrible a
movie made a mashed potato then we just
fought everything I'm defending Star
Wars he's crapping on Star Wars I'm
defending Star Wars which I realized is
one of the signs of abuse mmm they're
defending European yeah Stockholm
Syndrome
right I have Star Wars syndrome because
my friends are like Star Wars sucks I'm
like you don't know Star Wars anymore
don't worry sweets me like an angel with
no one's around you everything baby
Phantom Menace was my fault
[Laughter]
you